all right I think we're live so what's
going on everybody at Sean Evans host of
first we feast hot ones I'm here to do
this sort of live Q&A thing but before
we start a couple quick things that we
have to get out of the way first thank
you to all the hot ones fans out there
is such a ridiculous show we never
thought it would ever get the traction
that it has now but it's amazing to see
it grow the way it has and we're so
happy that we can deliver episodes on a
weekly basis so thank you everybody for
rocking with us I hope that you continue
to rock with us and then today during
the Q&A we have ten prize packs okay so
once from Heat inist Heat inist is where
you can pick up the hot ones hot sauce
so if you haven't picked up a bottle yet
you're curious about it you want to try
it if you send a really good question
you could win a bottle of hot ones hot
sauce and another hot sauce that heat
Ness is put together their amazing
curators of hot sauce so it's going to
be good and then we have five more prize
packs with hot ones merch you can get a
hat you can get a t-shirt so in total
ten prize packs so send your questions I
know right now we're going to work
through some Twitter questions some
YouTube questions but after that we're
going to the Facebook questions so if
you're watching us right now on Facebook
and you're like have a question that
you're dying to get out send it through
to us because once I get through all
these I'll start working on Facebook
questions and I don't care I'll be here
all day if I have to all right how
phones fans need to know so that's the
stuff that we need to get out of the way
and so let's just get into the Q&A here
so this first one looks like it's from
thrash ish and he asks who are your top
three interviewers mine are Terry Gross
nard warred James Lipton okay I think
those are great names nard waar is one
of these people that it doesn't matter
who he's interviewing I have to watch
because he always brings out these human
emotions and those are my favorite
that's my favorite thing to see sonar
guar will always hit people where they
don't expect to be hit and they'll have
some sort of genuine human reaction to
it so it doesn't matter who he's talking
to it doesn't matter if I've never even
heard of the person before I always have
to watch an argue our interviews that
said top three is top top three is tough
so
I would say the greatest interviewer
ever is Howard Stern
the second best ever is David Letterman
and then my third favorite and this is
going to be kind of a curveball but the
guy does not get enough credit is Andy
from Bravo Andy Cohen's an amazing
interviewer people watch watch what
happens live he's really good at asking
and framing questions so Andy Colin
low-key a guy who deserves much more
attention all right let's move on so
this is chef boy
Waddy oh and by the way I like that
question so since I like that question
too at thrashes you're getting a prize
bag you're gonna get some hot ones merch
all right moving on who who did you
think wouldn't get through but did and
who did you think would get through but
didn't that's a good question I think
that uh the people that I thought would
get through and didn't Jim Gaffigan I
thought Jim Gaffigan was gonna knock
down ten wings no problem and he ran
into some issues and ended up on the
Wall of shame but if I had money I would
have put it on Jim Gaffigan Jim Gaffigan
number one guy who I thought was gonna
make it through and did it and then on
the people that I didn't make it through
I thought wouldn't make it through but
did I gotta put Tommy Chong at the top
of the list a lot of people say that he
was the greatest like performance of all
time that he wasn't even fazed by the
hot sauces the guy is like in his 70s I
had no faith that he was going to get
through but he did other people that
surprised me were riff raff because I
saw the wheels coming off at about
question six and I was like oh like uh
this might not badly and then he just
rallied through I think he had some
issues afterwards but he did make it
through the show and then um I would say
that currency kind of surprised me in
the same way that he had such a heavy
facelift that I'm like there's no way
he's gonna live through this thing and
he made it all the way through um
Anthony Rizzo because he had like a game
that night or the next day I was like
well he's not
make it through but he's an athlete and
he's an animal and he's competitive and
he just wouldn't allow himself to quit
but those I think of the three people
that I didn't make it through and then
they did and then the one that I'm like
wish they had it through and didn't with
Jim Gaffigan all right hi Shaun which
White Sox player would you love to
interview Konerko Frank Thomas sale or
the number one Sox fan Barack Obama all
right here's the thing about politicians
is they're not actually sports fans like
they all like pandered sports fans for
whatever reason like to get some sort of
I'd like to have a beer with him faux
Konerko one of my all-time favorites I'd
love to talk to him Frank Thomas his son
sterling is actually a big hop one's fan
and we've actually like sort of talked
about trying to persuade his dad to do
the show because I idolized him growing
up and had Frank Thomas posters all over
my wall and wore Frank Thomas hats and
had the Frank Thomas Reeboks and only
cared about Frank Thomas and had to
watch Frank Thomas and I love when Frank
Thomas used to hit homeruns even though
he'd swing his back leg out like the guy
was just amazing but my number one
favorite white sock of all time and I
guess that's would have to interview
would be mark Burley I loved mark I love
mark Burley still love mark Burley I
feel like I have questions from mark
Burley I feel like mark Burley would be
a great interview so number one white
sock that I'd like to interview is mark
Burley also on there as I'd really like
to talk to Hawk Harrelson who does the
announcing and I'd like to talk to Ozzie
guillén because I think Ozzie guillén
would be an amazing interview all right
which guests do you feel avoided
answering some questions this is a good
question I think oh by the way hot ones
prize pack for Zachary bright who asked
me the White Sox question I enjoyed
answering that question which guess do
you feel avoided answering some
questions that's a good one I feel like
sometimes when we have athletes in here
that they're very good at skating
through questions because they kind of
have to they have so many strings
attached to him that if you ask him
something hard I think I asked Prince
Amukamara if he thought Roger Goodell
was worth being paid twice as much money
as Aaron Rodgers and kind of had to like
scape that even though he was fighting
off the hot sauces but I think athletes
just in general because the waters are
so muddy that like they kind of can't
even really say anything because they
have
me sponsors attached to them they have
the eyes the league on their back they
have like so many fans that are gonna be
upset if they don't say exactly the
right things I would say every time we
have an athlete on the show it always
feels like it's not totally right um
whose idea was the show and who was your
favorite interview both good questions
so this is from Brock daddy-o 8 1 9 the
ideas from Chris Shawn burger from first
we feast it was his idea and sometimes
you hear Schoenberger alluded to during
episodes sometimes we knocked down I
don't know if the third wall in the
fourth wall or whatever that phrase is
but we'll always be like Shawn Berger
like we need more almond milk or like
Shawn Berger where this were these wings
from Shawn Berger was his idea is kind
of inspired by Alexa Chung who used to
do these disruptive interviews on this
old English show called pop world and
then we have to shout out Tony Yayo from
g-unit because he helped us workshop the
idea you didn't have to but he was like
yo you should be eating wings too and I
was like yeah that's a good idea I don't
know why we didn't think of it so Chris
Shawn burger Alexa Chung and Tony Yayo
like a perfect storm coming together and
that's how you have how this one is from
Twitter user Gabriel Mueller sup guys
love the show is there any guest that
you guys invited that refused to come
because of his dislike of hot sauce
Jeremy Lin and Jeremy Lin if you're out
there open invite if you ever get over
it you and me know what's up you and me
have talked and I didn't he asked me the
question what do you want me to do not
answer it'd be dishonest that's not what
I do I asked him honestly so Jeremy Lin
get your let's go get over here let's
let's get over this whole thing together
all right from youtube user
Anthony Miranda why haven't you guys
acknowledged a teef wong's el I am so
happy that this question was asked I
can't
I've been chomping at the bit to answer
this one Eddie doesn't fit into a
category he came in here completely cold
and then cleaned the wing on not only
death sauce but then because he was just
so stunned by what was going on he then
cleaned the wing on Mad Dog 357
that is a very extreme thing to do just
off the street haven't even stretched
out yet haven't worked up your tolerance
and then to just clean the wing on the
two hottest sauces you can't put
somebody like that on the wall of shame
and that's a hot ones promise if you
come in here and before I even ask you a
question
clean the two hottest wings and then go
to the bathroom for 20 minutes and then
like physically endure what must have
been just like basically a torture
experience and then after going through
all that you come back and you deliver
one hell of an interview you're not
going on the wall of shame like I
wouldn't say that it was that he was a
winner I wouldn't say that it was like
the greatest performance of all time it
definitely wasn't that but he's just his
own category neither a winner nor a Wall
of shame person I'm not going to
apologize for it I'm not going to back
down from that I don't care if some hot
ones fans get upset about it that's just
it that's the deal that's the deal um
curious as to the wing making process
you guys use for each saw slash wing can
you elaborate on your prep and cooking
so this is a good question unfortunately
I'm not the best person to ask because
before the show starts I'm usually in
here I'm either like talking to a guest
or I'm doing a mic check or whatever so
I'll occasionally see bowls moving and
stuff and like things going on but I'm
not like right there watching over it
and I'm not saucing the wings myself so
from what I understand Chris
Schoenberger who we've talked about a
couple times now I'm probably will talk
about a little bit more later on in the
show what he does is he tosses them in a
bowl so it's like the first seven sauces
I think you just you put the sauce in a
bowl you toss the wing and that way you
have full coverage on the wing for these
last two or three maybe it's just the
last two you have to be a little bit
careful with how much hot sauce you use
because it can actually be a little
dangerous and we don't want to like
really hurt anybody so it's a little bit
of these two sauces like a smaller
amount than you'd have in these two but
we're still tossing them in the bowl
so that it has full coverage so that
nobody can
sort of hide from the hot sauce and then
of course on the last one we dab so it
leaves nothing to be questioned all
right Sean is there ever been a guest
reaction while filming hot ones they
cannot put in the finished video I would
say overall no I think we put pretty
much every reaction that we think is
awesome in the video there have been
times when somebody has like a line of
snot going or like a booger like
something just like gross and
off-putting we don't put that in there
our idea is not we don't want to
embarrass anybody we don't want to like
put anybody up that way but we want them
to be like checked by the hot sauces and
field those sorts of like hot sauce
punches in the face and then like you
know with Coolio like spitting in the
garbage can like if something crazy and
novelty happens we put it in there with
Eddie Wong we had you know the sound
going but we thought you know that was
enough hey Sean I've always wondered
what the hot one sauce tastes like what
comparison heat wise and taste wise well
I don't know it's for sale like if you
if you were that curious to how much it
cost you could just buy it so why don't
you just spend the twelve bucks all
right but it's good how about that it's
good it's it's it's really awesome sauce
I'm not just saying that because it has
my name on the bottle you have didn't
have my name on the bottle I said it
would still be my favorite sauce and
this whole lineup so we love those
sauces all right how many different
sauces did you guys try before you pick
the ten different sauces that you use on
the show so Chris Schoenberger always
coming back
he's the editor-in-chief first we feast
but before that he did a lot of food
writing with time out so he's tried
hundreds of hot sauces he's really into
it and then basically what he's done is
kind of curate this and then we've
played with it over time we've subs some
hot sauces out some do hot sauces in
we'll probably continue to do that as
the show evolves but basically we have
in his genius hot sauce mind a very
logical progression that we think really
tests people whether they're new to the
chili game whether they're expert level
chili heads like whatever we think we
have like a pretty formidable uh
act that we put on them and it's curated
this way from Krishna burgers brain all
right let's keep it moving let's keep it
moving I love this and having so much
fun
does dj khaled I have an act 24/7 or
does you really believe everything he
says it seems unbelievable I would say
dj khaled is a really interesting person
to talk to and to be around and I would
say that he's a good marketer I think
some of this stuff he plays up I don't
think that it's a coincidence that he
has ten million different key slogans
and they all end up on t-shirts that end
up in the DJ calots or like this is not
something that happens in a vacuum but
all of that said like dj khaled really
is dj khaled like it's not it's not a
total transformation like the the
fundamental is there the architecture
for the character that you see is in dj
khaled DNA okay what is Sean's recovery
time and process after each hot ones
episode so here's what you should learn
about me I'm somebody who travels four
times a month I'm on a [ __ ] plane but
I still have never filled out airline
miles like I don't have airline miles I
probably could go around the globe ten
times for free I still haven't figured
it out I still don't know how to do it
like even though it would take ten
minutes to figure out it's loved and
done it the reason I bring all that up
is because I don't do anything I don't
do anything to prepare I don't pop at
Toms I don't do a Pepsi ACC I don't even
know the tricks I don't even know what
would help
I've never had an antacid in my life I
don't think and so I just go in with
like basically like without stretching
and then afterwards I don't do anything
I if I were to go to the gym after a hot
ones episode that guy probably cancelled
those plans but otherwise it doesn't
change my life I just go home maybe I
get a Gatorade I crank the AC I throw on
some basketball shorts I just said it
chill out just try to chill out that's
basically it but I don't have like a
thing there's nothing I'm taken there's
nothing I'm drinking it's no performance
enhancers I'm I'm just real
who was stupid / crazy enough to use
Blair's Megadeth sauce bagel regularly
how did dabbing the last wing begin okay
so I don't know the first part of this
question I don't know who would be that
stupid but about how the dabbing began
is I don't even know like this may be
one of those things that some of the hot
ones hardcore fans could dig into
because I don't even know where it began
I I don't know like I know it happened
early on because we do it quite
frequently and I can't remember where it
started so I actually don't even know
the answer to that anyways we're also
gonna give up let's give up hot ones
merch packed the person asked me about
my recovery time I like that question
you're not an amateur so I want to run
my own challenge with friends but I need
a prize slash punishment for the winner
/ loser any suggestions I would say you
just you go for it you know I mean like
these things are their own wins and
their own losses so if you're somebody
who makes it to win seven and then can't
complete like maybe that's like the type
of person you are like maybe you almost
get to the top of the hill and then you
stop like that's punishment enough
having to look in the mirror after that
or having to go to bed at night after
that that's the punishment and on the
winners side if you just make it through
that's winning
that's a W if you just get through ten
wings and ten sauces I think that you
can feel proud of that you don't need a
trophy to validate yourself okay like
just remember the time that you got
through the sauces you don't need some
stupid reminder on your mantle Tapatio
or valentina which do you prefer
valentina it's not on our show but
that's the [ __ ] Valentin is great I
think I remember Valentina there how did
you guys handle Eric Andre after he
started smashing stuff well if you watch
the episode I what do you do I think you
just let the guys match stop I just
think you let the guy break stuff I
think you just let Eric Andre beat Eric
Andre
and then afterwards he just kind of like
slunk out actually Eric is the best Eric
after the show was in a rough spot but
he was kind of like yo do you want to
watch a the first episode of season 4
and this is like months and months ago
and I'm such a fan of his show that I
was like sure absolutely so
he and I got into a conference room
grabbed another couple complex employees
and while Eric was sort of like hunched
over holding his stomach we watched the
first couple episodes season four of the
Eric Andre show which was a lot of fun
why no politicians or authors on the
show the disarming nature of hot sauces
would be perfect it's amazing that you
bring that up politicians we reach out
to all of them they all dodge us you
know why because it shows to real so
Hillary we've reached out to and
actually to her credit her campaign
didn't just say like flat-out no to us
or didn't go radio silence I'm not sure
I'm much like I can share whatnot but
like I don't know like maybe we'll get
Hillary honestly but I would say like
everybody else is just radio silence I
don't want to mess with us um okay this
is from Twitter user eros trio RS trio
what are your plans or ideas on evolving
hot ones that's a really good question
and kind of you know I think that there
are a lot of fans who like the basic set
up and we like the structure too because
you can kind of compare how different
people react to different things but we
think about these things all the time we
think about little offshoot miniseries
that we could do I really enjoyed what I
did with chili Klaus last August where
we both ate a Caroline of Carolina
Reapers so I think that if we can do
more of those types of things and have
something where you know you have the
hot ones episode that drops on Thursday
but then maybe on Tuesday you do some
sort of like chili Klaus offshoot thing
or some other different mini series
these are the sorts of questions that we
have but complex proper we like like we
don't really want to make it a big
spectacle we don't want it to be a
reaction show like we really think of
ourselves as an interview talk show and
we want to stay that way
so evolving hot ones we hope to give the
fans more because they've been so into
it but um we don't want to do any
wholesale changes at least not right now
okay so I'm going to go to gchat because
we kind of worked our way through all of
the YouTube and Twitter questions which
are all awesome by the way I know that
maybe if I didn't give out five prize
packs we'll go through in the end and
trace back who we should give prize
packs to so I know I probably like
didn't give away all of them but don't
worry we're gonna give away all of them
okay Lee Edward is it hard to
concentrate on what your guests are
saying and their answers to your
questions while consuming the extremely
hot sauce that's a good question I think
I think actually that I'm in the
advantage in that case I think when I do
normal interviews without hot sauce
we're both operating at a hundred
percent and in those cases it actually
moves a little bit faster and this show
I feel like we're kind of stunning our
guests so I can kind of sit back and
play off down like to be honest with you
it's easier for me to work in this
environment than it is in some other
environment from being real about it all
right will you be changing up the hot
sauces for future episodes you know
we've done in the past I think we'll do
it in the future um I think that this
progression worked really well which is
probably why we've stuck with it for so
long but that's the thing that we talk
about sometimes we bring in some new
things bring in some fresh blood bring
in some new sauces who knows biggie or
Tupac would you rather eat wings with
that's a good question I've two of my
favorites [ __ ] you know what I think
Tupac would be the better hot ones
interview honestly like if I'm playing
them in my head right now
I think Tupac gives the better interview
I think that he's probably more
demonstrative I think that is he's
probably like a little bit crazier I
think like it could have the potential
to fly off the rails a little bit more
so Tupac alright what is this
Chicago rapid-fire do you think the
Chicago Cubs are going to win this year
so it's a really good team and they're
really fun to watch obviously have a
soft spot for Anthony Rizzo and all
these young guys that they bring up
they're all so good they're all so
exciting but here's the thing about the
Cubs been my whole life you know there
have been times before where they've had
stacked teams there have been times
before where they've been an inch away
from the World Series and they always
blow it so I think if you're the Cubs
you're just the team that blows it until
you prove otherwise
this is one of the best Cubs teams that
I've ever seen in my life but I've seen
arguably better ones fall flat on their
faces so this seems to be a new thing I
like what Maddon is doing the team's a
lot of fun to watch very talented but
until the Cubs prove otherwise I think
they're just a there Tina chokes
favorite Blackhawks player and player
you'd love to have on the show I'm not
the biggest hockey fan and here's the
thing about Chicago when I was growing
up Drew Abney and Adam Hartley were the
only two Blackhawks fans I knew and then
they started winning Stanley Cups every
year now everyone in Chicago is such a
huge Blackhawks fan but I've always kind
of stuck to my guns on that I never
watched a minute of hockey I get like I
tried to get a little bit into the
playoffs but I'm just I'm not a hockey
guy I'm just not a hockey guy um I think
like Quinn Ville the coach I think would
be a great hot ones interview I'd love
to have him on the show other than that
I don't know I just I'd have to learn so
much more about hockey I'd have to jump
into these guys heads more like
Blackhawks whatever I like this uh
Chicago rap in front of a guy come on
all right how do the hot sauce is on the
show compared to the Carolina Reaper you
ate none of them come close that's the
thing about Carolina Reapers and why you
shouldn't eat them the Carolina Reaper
is like ten times hotter than their
house hot sauce it's like basically
yeah I don't know it's it's flirting
with death for 10 hours after I ate that
Carolina Reaper I was like [ __ ] like
regretting it in a major major way it
was as much pain as I've ever been in my
entire life
from the moment I ate it until like the
next morning so Carolina Reapers are of
a beast all their own um they're
divorced what cat
what's a guest that you're trying to get
on the show so many great talents out
there in all forms of entertainment
would you love to interview on hot ones
so this is gonna sound sort of
self-serving but it's true like we
really are a show that's for the people
so we see who you guys request like I
know everyone wants Action Bronson
everybody wants bill burr and everybody
wants Tyler the Creator like we know who
our top five are we know who the people
request and then we reach out to those
people and are like here's the situation
we have the show a lot of your fans seem
to watch it they clamor for you to be on
it if you want to give the people what
they want like we want to give the
people what they want
come on our show that's kind of our
pitch and we've had a lot of success
with that the only thing I would say is
you got to kind of just be patient like
everyone's always like bill burr bill
burr beber beber we've talked to bill
burr and bill burr I don't I'm not like
involved in all the talks all the time
but it is kind of like oh this seems
kind of interesting and maybe when f is
for family season two comes out bill
Burrell pay us a visit we can give the
fans what they want and maybe it'll be
as awesome as everybody expects it will
be and maybe you can come back and do ba
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba but these are
all things that we don't figure out yet
until f is for family season two comes
out um the rock is a guy that I'm trying
to get in here uh really hard I've sent
some impassioned pleas to him basically
we look at all the people that people
want on we try to bring on people you
know we're always going to just do Chris
and I are always going to just do what
we want we're always going to just bring
people on that we think are interesting
that we think have cool stories to tell
and who we think our fans will really
enjoy but that's what it is we're for
the people and that's the thing
okay so I'm gonna answer one more maybe
two more I don't know um favorite rapper
interviewed that's a good question I
think the most fun I had during an
interview with a rapper and okay this is
gonna this is gonna probably surprise
hot ones fans but I really enjoyed my
time with Joe Budden the comments are so
divisive Oh Joe is like being rude to
Sean Joe this Joe that I [ __ ] love
Joe Budden I love all my conversations
with Joe Budden Joe is just Joe I like
that he doesn't come in here and pretend
to yuk it up with his best friend Shawn
like I like how he comes in here
challenging I like how he comes in here
guarded I like Joe Budden a lot I think
he's really interesting dude I could
talk to him all day long and for the hot
ones fans don't like to Joe Budden
episode I'm sorry but I would bring him
in here
again tomorrow if I could um and then
they asked can you shout out Chris
Murphy I'd love to shout out Chris
Murphy our editor Chris Murphy shot now
Chris Murphy and then you know when you
get to Chris Murphy shout outs that
you've really scraped the bottom of the
barrel
so that would mean that this thing is
done I think I forgot to forgot to give
away the heat inist prize packs because
I'm you know for people who are new here
hot ones is a bit of an amateur
operation I am a bit of an amateur TV
guy so I will give away the heat nest
packs will probably just give them to
the first five people that ask that I
answered Facebook questions for is that
cool all right um I'll wrap this up -
the hot ones fans out there thank you so
much for rocking with us this long it's
been 30 episodes but we want to give you
30 more and then 30 more and then 30
more after that and then I had a lot of
fun doing this so if it got the response
of people tuned in and flew tune in
again I'd love to do it again and
hopefully we won't have to wait 30
episodes for it hopefully we'll just you
know do it every 10 episodes or
something all right so thanks for
rocking with us new episode of hot ones
tomorrow morning at 11 a.m. Eastern it's
going to be a hot ones classic if you're
a hot ones fan you're going to really
love this episode and thank you so much
appreciate your time
[Music]